katie
cette discussion est terminée et je vais
faire un tireur d'élite non non emmène-moi avec toi
tu as raison
il se passe quelque chose de l'autre côté de la
rue
c'est la maison du nouveau voisin
[ __ ]
c'est le petit nouveau de l'autre côté de la rue
il s'appelle  robbie ouais sa mère est allée à
l'hôpital alors il va juste rester
avec nous
il n'a pas de parents je ne sais pas je n'ai
jamais rencontré sa mère
porte d'entrée ouverte maman
maman je ne pense pas que c'était un accident de
quoi tu parles  c'est vraiment
bizarre
vous voulez voir quelque chose de vraiment
cool avec le kinect que vous pouvez faire
ouais connecter des projets points de suivi
oh mon dieu qu'est-ce qu'il fait
il est trois heures du matin
robbie pouvez-vous me dire à qui vous
parliez personne ne
regarde ce qui est  ça ressemble à
un triangle avec un cercle juste
là c'est ça qu'est-ce que ça veut dire il
ne t'aime pas quoi qui ne
m'aime pas tu découvriras
pourquoi tu dois me dire ce qui se passe
je ne veux pas  tu vas te faire mal
je ne suis pas fou